one of the most contested issues
between christianity and islam is the
crucifixion
the death of jesus on the cross is taken
by christians as an almost
indisputable fact of history yet the
quran makes the bold claim
that jesus was not crucified
in this video we are going to see that
the quran has a remarkable insight
into biblical prophecy which proves that
the messiah
was saved by god
the new testament reports the following
encounter between jesus
and satan then the devil took him to the
holy city
and had him stand on the highest point
of the temple
if you are the son of god he said throw
yourself down
for it is written he will command his
angels concerning you
and they will lift you up in their hands
so that you will not strike your foot
against the stone
jesus answered him it is also written do
not put the lord your god
to the test here satan tested jesus
with a diabolical challenge biblical
prophecy foretold
that angels will protect you so prove it
right by throwing yourself from a great
height
now notice the response of jesus he does
not accuse satan of twisting scripture
rather he says it is also written which
is an affirmation that the prophecy
is indeed about him christian bible
commentaries confirm that the quoted
prophecy
is messianic for example
the jamison faucet and brown commentary
states
jesus said unto him it is written again
as if he should say true it is so
written and on that
promise i implicitly rely the pulpit
commentary states
the devil appealing to jesus
consciousness of abiding communion with
god
bids him in joy to the full promise of
god's protection
john calvin's commentary states satan is
not wrong
in proving from this passage that angels
have been given to christ
to wait on him to guard him and to bear
him on their hands
let's now take a closer look at the
prophecy applied to jesus
it's quoted from the old testament book
of psalms
no harm will overtake you nor disaster
will come near your tent
for you will command his angels
concerning you to guard you in all your
ways
they will lift you up in their hands so
that you will not strike your foot
against a stone
because he loves me says the lord i will
rescue him
i will protect him for he acknowledges
my name
he will call on me and i will answer him
i will be with him in trouble
and i will deliver him and honor him
with long life i will satisfy him and
show him my salvation
we can see that this prophecy in psalm
mentions that jesus will not be harmed
that the angels will guard him and that
god will rescue and deliver him
now this is where the prophecy gets even
more interesting
we actually find the hebrew name of
jesus yeshua
is the very last word in the prophecy
the hebrew word yeshua means salvation
so not only does this prophecy
explicitly foretell a saved messiah
it even foreshadowed his very name
yeshua
it is clear that any claims of a
crucified jesus completely contradict
this prophecy
saint augustine an early church father
and one of the greatest church
theologians in history
discussed psalm 91 in depth augustine
fully acknowledged that the mention of
the angels
lifting up was in reference to jesus
but when it came to those portions of
the prophecy that are problematic from a
christian perspective
such as the mention of being rescued and
protected augustine arbitrarily switched
his interpretation to the church
i.e the entire body of christians this
is despite the fact that the entire
prophecy
is addressing a single person which is
demonstrated by its consistent use of
pronouns in the singular
such as you he and him
this goes to show that even church
fathers struggled when it came to
reconciling
psalm 91 with the new testament claims
of a crucified jesus
this is why they had to resort to
twisting the prophecy
this is what the quran says about the
crucifixion
[Applause]
[Music]
the quran is crystal clear jesus was
saved from the crucifixion
being raised up to god alive and
unharmed
these verses show remarkable insight
when we analyze them in detail
the quran's claim that jesus was saved
by being raised up
perfectly mirrors the prophecy in psalm
91 which foretold that jesus would be
saved by being lifted up by angels
we can see that what the quran reports
about jesus
is in fact the fulfillment of old
testament prophecy that the messiah
would not be harmed
the foundation of christianity is the
crucifixion for the quran to come along
nearly 600 years later and challenge it
is quite bold
let's consider this from a psychological
perspective if muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him
was a false prophet then he would have
just gone along with new testament
claims that jesus was crucified
this would have made it easier for
christians to convert to islam so there
would have been a lot again
but islam is not about what is
convenient it's about the truth
the implications of the quran's position
are far-reaching
and actually go beyond islam one of the
reasons that jewish people reject jesus
is because of the crucifixion they know
that the messiah cannot be crucified
based on
old testament prophecies that we have
seen the messiah is supposed to be
someone who will be victorious
so any claim that he was whipped
tortured and died in humiliation is a
contradiction
so the new testament claims that jesus
died
ironically justifies the jewish
rejection of him
the quran removes the stumbling block of
a crucified messiah
and paves the way for the jewish people
to accept jesus
many have criticized the quran and its
audacity in challenging the new
testament crucifixion narrative
we have seen that it is in fact the new
testament accounts
written by anonymous authors decades
after jesus
which claimed that jesus was crucified a
complete contradiction
of old testament prophecy that the
messiah would be saved from death
these prophecies are a vindication of
the quran's position
and proof of his tremendous insight into
the actual life and mission of the
messiah
to learn the truth about jesus please
download your free copy of the book
jesus man messenger messiah from the
link below
you